so uh president joe biden had his
meeting with republicans at the white
house on monday night to talk about the
coveted relief bill
joe biden had proposed a 1.9 trillion
dollar package
republicans were allowed to express
to joe biden why they want a 618 billion
dollar package but it's now being made
abundantly clear that joe biden and
democrats
are hopefully ready to move ahead
without republicans that's what
uh joe biden's press secretary jen saki
said earlier this week at a white house
press briefing
it's what joe biden seems to be
communicating
and i hope that it's time to just go and
do it because at this point in time
i don't see the benefit to anybody on in
the democratic party and that includes
joe biden as well as democrats in the
house and senate of waiting with the
idea that maybe
some republicans might be okay with some
kind of completely
flaccid and pathetic uh compromise
between the 1.9 trillion and the 618
billion and at this point the
perspective should be
uh if republicans realize that the 1.9
trillion dollar package
and what it contains is popular even
with
some of their constituents it's
republican voters who want the stimulus
package too
if some republicans realize that then
maybe they'll vote for it in the house
or vote for it in the senate
if they don't realize that or realize it
but don't care
and every single republican decides to
vote against the 1.9 trillion
coveted stimulus package let them do it
at their own peril and what i mean by
that is
once their names are on the record
as saying no i'm against the coveted
stimulus package that is popular
even with many of my republican
constituents
well then it'll be up to republican
voters to decide whether they
want to re-elect those very same
republicans and my guess is
you will get some republicans to come
along with joe biden's plan because they
realize that many of their constituents
want it so joe biden has been widely
criticized for sitting down with
republicans on monday night
and not with democrats some hot take
saying
this is a right-wing president he talks
to republicans but not democrats i think
that that is
very far from what is going on i am
pleased increasingly
that joe biden and democrats aren't
budging on the 1.9 trillion dollar
proposal
joe biden had no need to meet with
democrats because joe biden and
democrats
mostly are on the same page about the
1.9 trillion dollar stimulus package
do the meeting with republicans because
joe biden said that he wanted unity he
said he wanted bipartisanship he said he
would work with republicans and he's
trying to
and that olive branch was this meeting
on monday night but it's time to stop
uh when joe biden said if we win these
georgia races two thousand dollar checks
go out immediately
that doesn't mean you negotiate with bad
faith actor republicans into march
and hopefully get checks out by the end
of march if not early april
enough time has gone by and if joe biden
and democrats don't move forward on the
1.9 trillion
put it at risk you know if republicans
really want to vote against it let them
do it
but if joe biden doesn't move forward
with this it is going to be a failure in
joe biden's column he was
very clear about what he would do and
what it would mean
to add senate control for democrats in
addition to joe biden taking the white
house from donald trump
and we will now see if they are going to
put their money where their mouths are
now
i think that the calculation to be made
um there's a couple of calculations here
when you think about this from a
political strategy
standpoint democrats by not budging on
1.9 trillion are doing a couple of
different things
number one i hope democrats and joe
biden realize
that if you meet somewhere in the middle
like imagine that democrats say okay you
know what
we want 1.9 trillion republicans want
618 billion
let's do 1.3 trillion or something like
that
a ton of republicans are still going to
vote against it
even though it will end up likely
passing and so republicans will end up
getting the benefit of it passing and
money getting to their constituents
while continuing to be able to virtue
signal about the debt
and the deficit and spending oh and what
not everybody deserves the money and all
of this sort of stuff
so the calculation i hope democrats are
making
is they know the plan is more popular
with the country
than the portion of people who voted for
joe biden in other words
this is a coveted stimulus package
that's popular with 60 65 70
of the country that's much more than the
share that voted for joe biden that
means
there are millions of republican voters
that like this plan
and they want it to pass if democrats
realize that and they realize
even if we negotiate with republicans
many of them will still vote against it
let's just move forward we have the
ability to do this via budget
reconciliation
assuming all 50 democrats in the senate
are on board which is
still a bit of a question mark but is
likely let's actually
put these republican senators in
particular and members of the house
in a position of having to vote against
something that their constituents want
let them vote no let them say it's bad
let them then have to go and explain
their votes to their constituents i
believe this is a political risk
very much worth taking for joe biden and
democrats i think the meeting was a
fine move for joe biden he's giving the
republicans an opportunity
to show they actually want to help the
american people
they present a counter offer that's so
pathetic and pitiful that it's
humiliating and embarrassing
and now put them in the position of
actually saying are you
really going to vote for nothing for
your constituents
are you going to try to prevent any
money from going out
because this is the package so i'm fine
with the meeting
i'm fine with not budging i'm fine with
moving forward without republicans the
question now is can joe biden actually
get it done
if he can get it done his early approval
on kovid and in general is going to
persist it's going to be buoyed for lack
of a better term
if joe biden fails to get this done
or something close to it like i think
even if joe biden did 600 billion in the
end
i think it would be considered a failure
he said two thousand dollar checks are
going out now we're already talking
about
adding 1400 to the 600 to make it a
total of 2000. that's already a
concession that i don't like to see
if biden can't get this done and get it
done in the next 10 to 14 days
it is going to be the first major
failure of the biden administration
let's hope it doesn't happen i i remain
cautiously optimistic that it will get
done
i like the way democrats are just saying
it's 1.9 trillion that's what it is
vote no if you want republicans i think
many will end up voting for it
let's talk about those tens of millions
of dollars
that donald trump raised after the
election
and before january 6th meant to
fight voter fraud in the courts and
met to support the republican incumbent
senators in georgia
both of whom lost donald trump
spent none of that money on the things
he claimed he was raising the money for
and of course anybody who looked at the
fine print as we did
would have predicted exactly this 76
million dollars
donald trump raised for what ultimately
was
a slush fund claiming i need the money
to challenge the results of the election
i need the money to make court filings i
need the money to help republicans win
in georgia so that republicans maintain
control of the senate
but through the end of 2020 not a dime
was spent on those causes maybe we don't
yet have reporting
for uh q1 spending maybe in those first
five days of january trump spent some of
the 76 million on the things he promised
to spend it on i doubt it he uh a a
republican
familiar with the fundraising
fundraising operation
said quote he put nothing back he didn't
care
he put all this money in the bank for
his own legal fights
he never cared about george's races but
not only that
he didn't even spend the money on vote
challenges and if you recall
back when trump was doing this we showed
you the fine print which
said uh depending on which fundraising
scheme we were talking about
50 percent or even more of every dollar
raised
could go towards the trump campaign
general fund to pay off trump's campaign
debt
he said it i mean listen he said it in a
deceptive way
in the fine print sort of like a
software end user agreement that's 30
pages long that nobody reads right i
mean
but he did do it and we were reporting
it and it was reported
so completely predictable that this is
exactly what was going to happen
uh jason miller was asked what what
happened jason
where did the money go and jason miller
so far has not responded for comment
now the the truth is trump may well need
this money for his own legal defense
and i think it's absolutely disgusting
that he's taking advantage of his own
supporters who he clearly never cared
about his people
but ultimately it's scammers and more
scammers
and more scammers taking advantage of
people who
are often scammers in their own ways
people who were
delighted to be bamboozled by trump in
2016
and wanted to continue believing that
trump was somehow going to figure out
something even though he lost the
election
this was the right these were the
perfect marks to be bamboozled in this
way
and ultimately the money is going to the
save america
leadership committee of trump this is
nothing more than a slush fund where the
money can be used for just about
anything trump wants if trump wants to
pay himself a salary out of this money
he could do it and it
is unbelievable that these folks fell
for it hook line and sinker despite the
fact that we were widely reporting that
this is exactly what was going on
now when you say these people fell
victims to a scam and and we should feel
bad for them
i don't know about that um you know it
it it is these
folks who say oh we don't need a nanny
state government
we don't need the government protecting
everybody from everything all the time
these are adults in the end these are
adults who presumably voted for trump in
2016
and or 2020. these are adults who
despite the fact that there was no
evidence they fell for the idea that
trump actually won and joe biden didn't
they fell for i mean look at look at
everything that they believed at some
point do they have
any responsibility themselves to figure
out what's true
they fell for the lie that donating to
trump might actually change the results
of an election even though
the election everything was happening on
schedule there were they said oh
december 14th is going to be delayed and
it wasn't
and then december what was you know
january 6 was going to be delayed and
the riots delayed it by a couple of
hours and it wasn't and then the
inauguration's not going
and it did they fell for it all do they
really deserve now to be
bailed out from the fact that they were
scammed not according to their own
political philosophy
which is no nanny state government none
of this stuff so
everybody but his cult knew this would
happen
they are uh they they it's hard to even
call them
suckers because they were so willing uh
i i don't want to call it stockholm
syndrome i don't know what to call it
but um they i have a hard time now
uh feeling as though they need to be
bailed out in some way because
trump put it at the bottom of the emails
it's how trump governed this was the uh
administration
the scam administration from day one uh
and these people got exactly what they
voted for which is trump ending up with
i believe it's
the 76 million i think it's 45 million
in some kind of joint rate fundraising
account
and then the other 31 million in that uh
defend america save america thing that
trump himself controls
so uh you know trump is going to do fine
financially very clearly
a lot of those folks who donated money
that they probably couldn't even really
afford to donate
may now have serious financial troubles
but they have only trump
and their own ignorance to thank for
that later by the way
we will talk about other other scams
that continue to
fester related to this administration
but the question i have for you
i want to hear from you on twitter where
you can find me at d pacman
should we feel bad for these people who
were swindled by trump's fundraising to
the point that
somebody should bail them out i believe
the answer is no
i'm willing to hear other ideas find me
on twitter
deepakman the david pakman show at
davidpakman.com
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership
is not just a feel-good thing you get
access to the world famous bonus show
every single day just for members as
well as commercial free audio
and video feeds of the show day in
and day out you can sign up for
membership very very quickly
at joinpakman.com that's join pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by all means use the coupon code
better21 all one word all lower
lowercase
become a member today
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
remember that our program depends on
funding from folks like you
through memberships which you can sign
up for at joinpacman.com it's quick it's
easy
almost every penny comes directly to the
david pakman show we're paying just two
percent
to swipe credit and debit cards grab a
membership
at joinpacman.com the coupon code is
available
that coupon code is better21 we look at
a lot of looney clips on this program so
it really takes a lot for me to say
this i have for you today one of the
most outrageous clips
i've seen in years and it is from right
wing propaganda channel
newsmax and it involves the my pillow
guy mike lindell
now i won't do a big lead up but i want
to make sure we're all on the same page
if you've been following politics for
the last year you might know
that my pillow is a company that sells
pillows on right-wing media i believe
even pajamas as well
and the founder mike lindell is a
right-wing religious nut who thinks
donald trump
was or is a gift from god to the
american people
lindell somehow because this country is
so backwards
ended up in a position of proximity to
power he was actually close to donald
trump he was advising trump about how to
possibly
stay in power despite having lost the
election to joe biden
mike lindell appeared on newsmax
yesterday and started spouting off about
dominion
voting systems which didn't go well
because newsmax like many other networks
and rudy giuliani and others
newsmax has been threatened by dominion
with a lawsuit if they keep repeating
these
false claims about dominion voting
systems so the hosts when mike lindell
brings up dominion voting
the hosts try to change topics and it
doesn't go well
mike lindell just keeps talking it
culminated with one of the hosts
walking off the set but first when mike
lindell brings up
a dominion the host starts saying we
can't verify any of this
clearly trying to avoid a lawsuit but
mike lindell just keeps going
so what happened what happened with your
twitter account
and the uh company page well first mine
was taken down because we have all the
election problem with these domain
machines we have 100 percent proof
and then i when they took it down um
thank you very much mike mike you're
talking about machines
uh that that we at newsmax have not been
able to verify
any of uh those kinds of allegations we
just want to let people know
that there's nothing substantive that
we've seen and let me read you something
there
while there were some clear evidence of
some cases of vote fraud
and election irregularities the election
results in every state were
certified and newsmax accepts the
results as legal
and final the courts have also supported
that view
so okay so he gets that on the record
but mike lindell doesn't care he
will not be dissuaded from talking about
dominion voting systems
let's keep going and it just continues
to escalate
we wanted to talk to you about
cancelling
culture if you will we don't want to
relitigate
the the allegations that you're making
mike
because we we understand where you are
so
let me ask you this do you think that
this should be
temporary because it appears to be
permanent could you make an argument
that it is temporary right
could you make an argument that this
could be a temporary banning rather than
permanent no i want it to be a permanent
because
you know what they did this because i'm
revealing all the evidence on friday
of all the election problems with these
machines so i'm sorry if you
okay can i ask our producers can we
get out of here please i i don't want to
have to keep going over this
newsmax have not been able to verify any
of those allegations
so absolute and complete chaos
one of the funniest news clips that i've
seen
and here in this last segment if you're
listening you might
hear noise as the host walks off if
you're watching you will see
the host just walk right off the set
mike hold on a second everybody hold on
a second mike mike hold on one second
uh let's talk a little bit about just
what is happening
overall in terms of censorship i'm
trying to
cancel out my company and myself in this
country it's cancelled culture
so by that point by that point
one of the hosts is just gone uh
outrageous
and amazing and the real question is why
do they keep having mike lindell on
at all they know that this is lindell's
shtick
newsmax sees the billion dollar lawsuits
by dominion against rudy giuliani
and others they got a threat letter
themselves saying
stop these defamatory claims and they
decided as a company
hell no we can't afford that so then why
do you have michael and dell on when you
know that that's what he's been talking
about for months now
and i want to be really really clear
this is not about ethics newsmax is
depraved and
horrible they are willing to spread
anything and in fact
for a month or six weeks after the
november election
they welcomed every one of these
lunatics on sydney powell
rudy you know whoever to talk about
dominion to talk about voter fraud
massive voter dumps all of this
different stuff
this is not about ethics it's about
money
i don't think i've ever seen uh
defamation claims and warnings
used as effectively as we've seen
dominion use them in response to
right-wing media they have right-wing
media hosts
literally walking away when the topic of
dominion voting machines
is brought up they're they're asking
producers
cut his mic because they've so
effectively been
uh uh notified we will sue you
if you keep allowing this stuff on the
air and and i think the most important
takeaway is
there's a few there's a few important
takeaways here takeaway number one
how insane is this country that the my
pillow guy
became close to the president because of
his ideas about how to steal an election
and as i've said before
trump saying i'm running wouldn't have
done the damage it did
were not the american electorate or at
least part of it so susceptible to a con
an obvious con man like donald trump in
the same way
mike lindell wanting to be an adviser to
the president
would be meaningless if we didn't have a
president who thought it was a good idea
and um that that's one takeaway the
other is
i said it but i want to say it again
newsmax is not concerned with the truth
all of a sudden and that's why they're
saying to michael and dell don't talk
about dominion
they're scared of the lawsuit they knew
the truth from day one which was joe
biden won the election that's it
but they kept airing this crap because
it got them clicks
but now the risk of a billion dollar
lawsuit is too big for the revenue they
were probably making on youtube or
wherever else by repeating this stuff so
an
immensely compelling clip to watch
and think about i mean if what you're
saying is too outrageous for newsmax to
air
you know it's bad and you know that
you're off the deep end
hey this is just unbelievable
the pro-trump election fraud lawyer
lynn wood is under investigation
for possibly voting illegally himself
this is being reported by wsb-tv
in atlanta uh lynnwood
a lawyer filed lawsuits to try to steal
the election for trump held rallies to
try to
steal the election for trump claimed
people voted illegally in the 2020
presidential election
and wsb-tv in atlanta georgia can now
report
that the state is investigating lynn
wood
for potentially having voted illegally
in the state of
georgia reporter justin gray was able to
confirm yesterday
that the georgia secretary of state is
looking into
whether lynn wood was even eligible to
vote in the state of georgia
and whether he actually broke the law
when
he voted and potentially wrongly claimed
to be a georgia resident
uh linwood said it's 1776 in america and
we're not going to let them take
our freedom that freedom being that he
claimed trump was the rightful winner of
the election
and people voted illegally for joe biden
or the numbers were messed with or the
machines were messed with or whatever
but he himself
he himself lynn wood may have voted
illegally
of course for donald trump in the state
of
georgia the incredible
detail here is that sources
at the georgia secretary of state's
office say the reason they're even
investigating linwood
is that linwood emailed their office and
said
i moved to south carolina he admitted to
them quote i have been domiciled in
south carolina for several months
after purchasing property in the state
in april
presumably the reason linwood was
telling this to the georgia secretary of
state
was related to taxes you want to when
you change states
uh i don't i don't even know the tax
rates in georgia and in south carolina
but
very often when you change states and
you go to a lower tax state or at least
you want to avoid having to file taxes
in two states
even if the tax rates are similar you
want to make sure that the state you've
left
knows you have severed your relationship
with them when people move from new
york to florida this is a whole legal
and accounting thing where
how do you demonstrate you really are no
longer
responsible for any taxes in new york so
lynn wood
said i'm domiciled in south carolina
presumably for tax purposes and as a
result of that
the secretary of state in georgia is now
looking at whether
he even should have been legally allowed
to vote in georgia in november
so this is all uh yeah maybe linwood was
right after all
and people did vote illegally and he
meant himself
maybe he really did have that personal
knowledge because it was he himself who
actually did it
and while they're at it check trump's
voting as well moving from new york to
florida voting by mail it's all very
very suspicious right
endless projection from these people it
never ever ever ends and there is no
there is no hypocrisy too great there is
no instance of protect
of projection that goes beyond what
these people are capable of
and we've talked before about how for
all the talk about voter fraud
the people getting caught are either
republicans doing it
or republicans trying to quote test the
system to show how easy it is to do
and it turns out it's not actually that
easy because they keep getting caught
we'll follow the investigation into
lynnwood and whether
he did or didn't vote illegally but it
is um it's
is it fair to call it a comedy of errors
i don't know that these are really
errors these really do seem like
fraudsters
uh maybe we need a different term for it
we'll have more on this
on the david pakman show instagram page
make sure you're following us
at davidpakmanshow on instagram while
you're there
follow me on instagram at david.pacman
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous at this point
and the daily commercial free tv show
by making those pledges at patreon.com
pakman show this is audience supported
media we depend on the support of our
viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us
on tv or even listen on the radio
patreon.com slash david pakman show
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
we've been wondering whether republicans
in the house of representatives and in
the senate are
ever going to denounce these outrageous
new members of congress we're talking
about people like
marjorie taylor greene lauren beaubert
madison cothorn or are republicans going
to be supportive of these new radicals
or are establishment republicans going
to avoid talking about them altogether
and we're going to look through two
examples
today we have our first example and it's
a really good one this is
steve scalise steve scalise is a
republican congressman
also the house minority whip and he was
on fox news yesterday morning and he was
asked about comments
made by congresswoman marjorie taylor
green
and somehow he was able to abort that
question
and talk about joe biden
china and carbon it sounds like
this couldn't possibly happen but it's
exactly what happened let's take a look
at the video clip
marjorie taylor green the freshman
congresswoman from georgia
under some fire for past comments i'm
going to be meeting with
uh majority minority leader kevin
mccarthy later
and liz cheney is going to have to
talk to some of her members on the
republican side who would like to see
her removed from her leadership position
because of
supporting impeachment and voting for
that
based on your conversations are more of
your members supportive
of green or cheney well first of all
i've rejected those statements by
marjorie and you know i think
uh we're going to be talking tomorrow in
conference we're going to have an
in-person meeting
uh you know in in the capitol where
we're going to be talking through a lot
of these issues internally
look first of all we're very united in
our opposition to the devastating
economic hits that president
biden has been doing in his first two
weeks the paris accord we haven't even
talked about
will crush american manufacturing and
send it to china where they emit five
times more carbon
to make things like steel that
pennsylvania will not be able to make
if they get that so we're going to be
talking about all those things
steve scalise is a horrible ideologue
but he's also
somewhat of a realist and he does seem
to realize that marjorie taylor green
is bonkers i mean just cuckoo but he
still manages to pivot
on a question about marjorie taylor
green and talk about chinese carbon and
joe biden
and it's just out of this world what do
you think about marjory taylor green
he talks about carbon and there's
a difficulty here for republicans
because
until it's clear otherwise they have to
assume
that the types of people who support
marjorie taylor greene are an important
part of the electorate
to the republican party they have to
assume until it's proven otherwise
that a lot of the supporters and voters
of marjory taylor green all are are also
the types of people
that uh people like steve scalise need
to continue
uh um getting support from and i'm not
saying that scalise would otherwise
denounce marjorie taylor greene
but he must be aware of the fact that
denouncing her straight up
might not play well with the portion of
the voters that he and his party need
and in the end failure to act is a form
of consent
and all of these republicans who no
doubt will fail to do
a damn thing about these outrageous
radicals that got voted in during the
last election
are complicit but they are trying to
sort of thread a needle
to avoid consequences as much as
possible for the republican party and
for themselves that's all they're doing
you know we talked earlier about newsmax
now doesn't want anybody talking about
dominion voting systems and they
tried to kick off my pillow guy mike
lindell when he wanted to talk about
dominion voting systems
newsmax has not all of a sudden found uh
decided that the truth is important
newsmax has not all of a sudden decided
that journal
journalistic ethics matter to them these
things are financial pragmatic
calculations and it's the exact same
thing with with steve scalise and
case in point the further we get from
january 6th
without accountability the more and more
that republicans like steve scalise are
going to be able to just opt out of
condemning
the people who uh were most responsible
in the republican party
for inciting that riot which certainly
includes donald trump at the top of the
party
but uh increasingly also includes people
like marjorie taylor greene and lauren
bobert you know after the access
hollywood tape
some of them claimed to be outraged but
then they weren't anymore and then
you know just months ago when kelly
leffler was asked about that tape
she was able to get away with saying i
don't even know what you're talking
about i've never seen that tape i don't
know a thing about it
and um the the sort of last thing before
we move on to the next clip here
is we've been looking at a lot of
interviews over the last few days that
republicans have given on
cnn fox news newsmax oan
etc notice the complete lack of policy
platform in the republican party right
now yeah i know
that that's been the case for a while in
some bigger picture sense that it's been
a lot about just
prevent democrats from doing stuff but
right now
there is a completely uh
they're they're not even pretending to
care about policy they say
joe biden is doing too many executive
orders they say
where are we going to get the money for
all of this stuff that joe biden wants
to do with the coveted stimulus 1.9
trillion dollar package
and they say why hasn't joe biden more
quickly dealt with the virus even though
he's only been in
office for two weeks there is a they
aren't even pretending
to have actual policy proposals of any
kind
with the exception of that pathetically
small
stimulus package that they are proposing
as an alternative to joe biden's it's
about being anti-biden
it's about being anti-democrats and it's
about um
a pr essentially at this point and if
they had fought the virus
with half the conviction that they've
been using over the last 14 days to
fight joe biden
we would be much better off in this
country we would have had far fewer
covet deaths in this country but sadly
that's never been their priority
let's now look at another example of a
republican confronted with the comments
of marjorie taylor green
okay so we already looked at steve
scalise
turning a question about marjorie taylor
green's outrageous comments
into an answer about china joe biden and
carbon
let's now go to our second example of
the day
this is republican congresswoman nancy
mace asked on fox news about the
ludicrous things that marjorie taylor
greene has said
remember we've uncovered videos of
marjorie taylor greene talking about
jewish space lasers as the cause for
california wildfires
marjorie taylor greene uh being a 911
denier
marjorie taylor green um talking about
political violence as a good thing as
something that that needs to be done on
and on and on
republicans are being asked to comment
nancy mace is a republican congresswoman
from south carolina
some believed not me but
some believed that she was a more
moderate rational voice in the
republican party
she went on fox news yesterday she was
asked about marjorie taylor green's
comments and she actually
to her credit she seemed to concede that
marjorie taylor green
is crazy but she played the both sides
games saying there are crazy people on
both sides
and then gave a number of false
equivalencies so let's take a look
but there are crazies on both sides of
the aisle we've seen that
um you know it's not just republicans
that have our own issues
democrats have them too we've seen
maxine waters
tell folks to go and threaten and harm
members of the
trump administration right um we've seen
crazies on both sides of the aisle
we do have to i think address some of
these issues but you know some of these
things and i'm learning about them today
and this week too were said before she
was elected and georgia voters still
elected her
just a few years ago we saw democrat
another democrat from georgia
cynthia mckinney assault a capitol hill
police officer and nothing was done
after
that either so we've got to look at
precedent we've got to have this
conversation we have to address it and
if we do a better job
of holding ourselves accountable we can
also hold the left accountable as well
we
we have to have that moral authority and
that means addressing some of these
situations
so listen if you if you need me to find
something positive about that
she does seem to be saying that marjorie
taylor green is crazy
she is drawing false equivalencies to
maxine waters though
and also saying this stuff was said
before marjorie green
was elected is is not particularly
relevant
this is gaslighting this is what about
ism two side stuff
and it's a complete farce and at least
she's admitting marjorie taylor green is
crazy
but maxine waters never followed around
an 18 year old kid
that was at a school during a school
shooting
accusing that kid of wanting to take her
guns away as marjorie taylor green did
to david hogg maxine waters never said
that there were wildfires started by
i don't know catholic space lasers or
anything like that
and by the way even if these examples
from the other side were equivalent
they're in the past and they have
nothing to do
with nancy mace and republicans now
dealing with marjorie taylor greene who
is in her own party
at this point in time nancy mace
actually has
a sort of clever approach to a lot of
these interviews i've seen other
interviews where when nancy mace is
asked what you would think or questions
she really has to answer
she'll sort of fast talk through a bunch
of distortions and lies it's sort of a
gish gallop technique
and very often anchors or interviewers
even either don't have the wherewithal
or skill to point it out or just don't
have the time because a lot of these
segments last
you know four minutes it's hard to
refute six lies in four minutes
and nancy mace used very similar talking
points
on cnn over the weekend they are
terrible talking points
but she is getting away with them and uh
as i said before
i am disgusted that republicans
even with these people aren't just
straight up calling them out and saying
there's no room for this insanity in the
republican party obviously it's
disappointing they're not doing that
i'm not surprised that they're not doing
it but there is a political
calculation happening here where to some
degree i think they believe
the further they get from january 6th
the further they get from trump being in
office
the more they can kind of just shut
their mouths about these people
and claim that they're about legislation
and they're about stopping socialism and
government takeovers of health care and
uh reducing the deficit all that stuff
that they pretend to care about
and just sort of not comment on people
like marjorie taylor green lauren bobert
madison cawthorne and others
so ultimately i believe that the test as
to whether these radical new members of
congress will become
a significant part of the republican
party will be whether they get reelected
in 2022
democrats do have a path to expelling
these folks
from committee assignments but
it would take republicans to really be
able to get them out of the house of
representatives i don't expect it to
happen
we talked on the bonus show yesterday
about how there have only been five
expulsions in the history of the house
three of them were in the 1800s against
members who were straight up supporting
the confederacy
the other two were in the 20th century
was one of them in the 21st
the other two were in the modern
political era and they were
for members of congress who had actually
been convicted of crimes and so
i am not optimistic at all that we are
going to see these folks expelled
of course it says a lot about the
republican party that they're unwilling
to really take a stand against them
but that's not particularly surprising
to me i'd be shocked if it were to you
if you've been paying attention to what
has happened to the republican party
um even casually over the last few years
we will take a quick break much more
coming up
in just moments the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
did you know the david pakman show is on
all sorts of different platforms find us
on youtube
at youtube.com forward slash the
davidpakman show
and on steemit the blockchain based
publishing platform at
steemit.com david pakman
that's s-t-double-e mit.com
forward-slash at david pakman
david pakman show at davidpakman.com
donald trump has thankfully been missing
from the public eye almost completely
since leaving office 14 days ago today
and by the way
two weeks already joe biden has been
president it doesn't feel like it it
feels like he was just sworn in
yesterday but it's been two weeks
trump's been missing but his son eric
trump is quickly
challenging his dad for the most
humiliating
and cartoonishly farcical interviews i'm
not totally clear on what eric trump is
trying to accomplish
by doing interviews but he was
interviewed last night on the sean
hannity fox news
propaganda program what he did achieve
was creating a caricature of the
sycophantic
brown-nosing defender of donald trump
and in particular
a son who is desperate for the approval
of his father that he never
really seems to have gotten it's sad in
a way
let's look at some clips these are
painful to watch in this first clip eric
trump
rewrites history and says there has
never been
a more beloved political figure than
donald trump
i know in the history of america
they know he did a great job for this
nation they know that there's never been
a more beloved political figure in our
country's
history there are 75 million americans
who would follow him to the end of earth
i mean
they love the man they love what he
stands for it's not just that trump
wasn't the most beloved political figure
there has been no president in the
modern political era
that was less popular than donald trump
donald trump not once during his entire
presidency
achieved a 50 percent approval rating in
the gallup daily tracking poll
that's never been the case for any
president in the history
of modern polling trump and melania
had the lowest average approvals of any
president and first lady for as long as
polling has been done
and eric trump it's just opposite
everything is
you know they wrongly talk about
orwellian uh and say things are
orwellian when they're really not
orwellian
uh double speak saying the opposite of
what is is true
actually is something that played a role
in george orwell's 1984.
eric trump says this is the most beloved
president in history
uh most never mind president he says the
most beloved political figure in history
and he is the least popular president in
history about whom we have data
then sean hannity tees up a softball for
eric trump
about how their victims the you know
melania is a victim
eric trump ivanka donald trump they're
they're all treated so terribly and eric
trump still can't put together a
coherent answer
um but there's been nothing but from the
day
your father and melania trump came down
the escalator trump tower it's been
never-ending harassment for your dad
your
you your family don jr
ivanka every baron even melania
everybody
and it continues now we know the outcome
of this latest charade
i played the double standard and i'm
just curious as you hear the remarks of
democrats and compare them to the
remarks of your dad
what your thoughts are
listen sean i was there you know 20
minutes after election 20 minutes after
election day on in
you know 2016 it was a beautiful day i
remember the washington post
writing that story which is this is the
you know this is the minute that
impeachment begins and they tried and
they tried to get him with the russia
hoax and they tried to get him with
ukraine and they tried to take down
kavanaugh and they tried to get him
again
and they tried to manufacture everything
you know under the sun against my father
against all of us they do it every
single day they continue to do it
ah the poor trump family wow
have you ever seen a more
privileged set of people
portray themselves as bigger victims and
martyrs than this family josh hawley
being on fox news every other day
speaking to a national audience about
how he's been silenced
yeah that's funny this is even crazier
and they claim to be tough
they don't want snowflakes all of this
nonsense and they are the
thinnest skinned family who have spent
four i mean really five years now
obsessed with the idea
that nobody's been treat been treated
worse than them
there's been no bigger victims in
america in the world
than the trump family the most powerful
person in the world for four years
and his family want you to think
they are the victims of everything of
the media
of the democrats of whatever it's
unbelievable
last clip eric trump says
that the country is soon going to miss
donald trump and honestly i think people
are going to miss donald trump
really quickly i think they're going to
miss him really really quickly because
some of these policies that they're
enacting these executive orders you know
40
40 in the first day um are madness sean
they're just madness
well you know it's it's interesting
again trump left office
with the lowest approval of his
presidency he was the least popular
president in the history
of the modern political era but in
addition eric is just lying on the facts
and this is a good opportunity to talk
about the executive orders eric there
said that
joe biden signed 40 executive orders on
his first day in office this is not true
the list of executive orders is public
any one of you can find it it's out
there
on january 20th joe biden signed nine
executive orders nine not forty you
might like those executive orders
you might not you might wanna reform the
executive order system
but he didn't sign forty executive
orders on day one he signed nine
on the second day of his presidency joe
biden signed
eight executive orders eric trump says
it was 40 on day one actually
it was 17 over two days and in total
including the executive orders joe biden
signed yesterday on immigration
joe biden has signed 28 executive orders
in 14 days not 40. you can debate
executive orders
you can debate their contents you can
debate their merits you can debate
what shouldn't shouldn't be done via
executive order is there something
damaging to the political system to the
fact that every president feels the need
to use executive orders to undo what
their predecessor did
all valuable debates but if you start
with a lie
that joe biden signed 40 on day one when
he really signed nine
the debate is worthless because you're
starting with a lie truly
a pathetic figure in american politics
and
that could apply to a lot of people i'm
talking about eric
trump and i'm wondering is he going to
keep doing this for the next two years
for the next four years
appearing on fox news to talk about how
everybody misses his dad and how
terrible joe biden is and i think it's
still a question mark
it's looking like donald trump is just
sort of disappearing we've not heard
from him for two weeks
when it comes to eric trump don jr has
been going absolutely crazy on twitter
for the last two weeks
there's rumor or the idea that maybe
eric trump's wife lara trump plans to
run for senator
in north carolina still a question mark
as to whether these characters are going
to
try to keep playing a role in american
politics let's hope they don't and again
the entire eric trump thing eric trump's
entire presence to me
reeks of a son desperate for their
father's approval
more than anything else the associated
press is reporting
that dozens of former bush
administration officials george w bush
are leaving the republican party because
they feel it has become the trump cult
at this point in time
they are claiming to be dismayed by the
failures of the republican party
including donald trump and his false
claims of election fraud which these
uh dozens of officials claim is the
catalyst for them
leaving the republican party some
served pretty high up in the bush
administration
they said that they were hopeful that
trump losing would lead
party leaders to immediately move on
from donald trump
all unanimously denounced trump's claims
that the election was stolen
of course that didn't happen most
republican officials stuck with trump
and the officials that are now
abandoning the republican party are
saying
they don't even recognize the party that
they once
served as employees of government some
have formally left the republican party
others are moving over to being
independents
and uh they have included such
statements as the republican party as
it uh as i knew it no longer exists
i'd call it the cult of trump that's
jimmy gurule
who was under secretary of the treasury
for
terrorism and financial intelligence
in the bush administration christopher
purcell
who worked for george w bush said the
number is growing
every day of former bush administration
officials who are leaving the party or
cutting ties with the party
now i have a few thoughts on this first
of all
these are not heroes okay they said
nothing for a long time
if the truth is that they didn't like
how trump was operating
as evidenced by what happened after the
november election
trump operated the exact same way for
the four years leading up to it
trump operated the exact same way before
he even joined
the or before he was elected but after
entering into the republican primary so
you know they said nothing for a long
time
i don't believe these republican
officials would be doing this
if the insurrection had somehow
succeeded if donald
trump after talking about the election
having been stolen
had actually figured out a way to steal
it back which was never going to happen
but
if it did i don't think these
republicans would be saying i'm leaving
because it was wrong for trump to steal
the election they would still have their
mouths shut
like they did for the four years that
donald trump has been president so
the headline should be dozens of bush
administration officials
are suddenly desperate to distance
themselves
from the fiasco that their movement has
fueled and pumped up for decades and
this is the most important thing
when people like you know mitt romney
say something
uh that makes nominal sense and we say
wow there there's a voice of reason and
and whatnot
it is true that mitt romney's framework
is completely different from that of
donald trump there's no question about
it whatsoever
and uh many of them may be sincere in
their disdain for what trumpism has
turned the republican party into
but they all played a role in turning
the republican party into that
this goes back to reagan in the 80s
starting with the welfare queen stuff
and appealing to this kind of
anti-intellectualism
that runs rampant on on the republican
side it continued
with newt gingrich uh being speaker of
the house
in the early 1990s i believe i believe
he became speaker in 1994
um which was the first midterm election
under bill clinton
and republicans scaling up this sort of
cartoonish
um fact-free opposition
to what bill clinton at the time was
offering
and of course it exploded under the
anti-intellectualism of george w
bush and on and on and on so it's fine
for a lot of these people now to try to
save their own skin
by claiming to leave the party they have
every right to do it but whatever and
the
the important takeaway is not only did
they
not do this while trump was president
even though the arguments they made
would apply during the presidency as
well
they all gladly worked for
administrations that are responsible
for the conditions that led to a
republican party where trump could win a
primary
trump could never have won a primary on
the democratic side there are
differences between the democratic and
republican parties
there's too many similarities in some
cases but there are important
differences
the reason trump was able to win the
republican primary
relates to george w bush and everybody
who served under him
it relates to uh george h.w bush
it r all the relates to newt gingrich
and ronald reagan so yeah okay they're
trying to distance themselves but
uh they they are a big part of why trump
even won the republican primary in 2016.
now there are also many republicans
still writing off the attempted
insurrection
there there are actually some people on
the left as well
writing off the insurrection but many on
the right
still are right-wing terrorism has
escalated to the point
that it almost led to uh elected
officials getting killed
and uh they are now for the most part
with joe biden in office immediately
going back to what aboutism debt and
deficit and
uh trying to uh pretend as though the
january sixth insurrection never
happened the the
i i hate to even bring this up but um
look up hitler's beer hall push and why
republicans
now so quickly moving past what happened
on january 6th
is dangerous there was this you know
laughable
failed coup attempt by hitler hitler was
convicted of high treason
served nine months and we know what
happened later
now i'm not saying trump is hitler
all i'm saying is it's scary to me how
quickly republicans are willing to move
on and pretend it never happened
and it's scary to me that a lot of
people think this is over
while we have people like marjorie
taylor green lauren beaubert and others
in the congress and most republicans
already pretending that the thing never
went down on january 6 the way it did i
believe that a lot of this has just
begun
i hope i'm wrong i'm worried that i am
right
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192davidp
there's a really great question brought
up in today's voicemail take a listen to
this
hello david i was watching your show
today and uh
or listening to your show and there was
that uh interview with the guns rights
activist and marjorie taylor green and i
was just wondering because she started
talking about socialists
um why does everyone think that
socialists are anti-gun when
you know marx and lennon and mao all
wrote you know explicit
or explicitly pro-gun um do they just i
mean i know they're operating bad face
but do they just
fundamentally not have any idea i guess
what socialism is
or i don't know
yeah this this is a this is a really
excellent question um
there is this reflexive inclusion
whenever people talk about
socialists wrongly and again there's
almost no socialist in positions of
power in the united states it's a
complete and total farce but
you will often hear about the socialists
who want to disarm you
that is a completely uh non-based in
history
claim and there are lots of examples of
this if you look back at an 1850
speech written by karl marx and engels
they say
under no pretext should arms and
ammunition be surrendered
any attempt to disarm the workers must
be frustrated by force if necessary
there are many socialist uh uh
theorists who supported
armed workers in part of their support
of the proletariat maintaining power
recognizing that
maybe the gun would be a useful way for
them to gain power
over the capitalists mao under mao
villages factories all sorts of
different units
you know discrete units were expected
and encouraged
to have armed militias that were
self-organized and were
they had weapons um under lenin
lenin wrote on disarmament where
lenin said an oppressed class
which does not strive to learn to use
arms
to acquire arms only deserves to be
treated like slaves
lenin's perspective as i understand it
is
uh having weapons prevents you from
being treated like a slave
by the capitalist by the employer by the
owners of the means of production so
not only do they not i mean yes the if
if you're wondering
does the right understand x the the
answer is probably not
and not only do they misunderstand what
socialism is and who is a socialist
they very casually and wrongly talk
about
anti-gun socialists when historically
there is much pro-gun sentiment among
some of the
most important and notable uh socialist
marxist figures in history but i i don't
think they care i don't think
watching this clip is going to change
their minds they'll just keep repeating
the same stuff
on the bonus show today we will talk
about jeff bezos
uh planning to step down as amazon's ceo
we will talk about the capital rioters
quickly selling each other out
to try to lower their own possible
prison sentences and we will talk about
oregon
decriminalizing possession of drugs
huge step in oregon we will talk about
the implications oregon
as someone's uh somewhat someone i know
says it but i say
oregon all of those stories and more
on today's bonus show sign up at
joinpakman.com
to get instant access